[Music]
we live chair when you're
ready thank you everyone when we come
for our buiness
come in front of you m button is not M
and press
will
come
finish I'd like to first introduce those
people here tonight introduce themselves
I am coun John for the purposes of even
my name is j I'm the leg officer here
today
offic
[Music]
good evening Chris L on behalf of the
appli
DPS sh inform in relation to Wheels I
can
perhaps make matters reasonably short
for you um this was an application that
was correctly made in all form you've
got it on your agenda item to um there
was a representation made uh in theate
professional
authorized authorities as to very
various conditions about H verification
and training those those that those
representations have been withdrawn uh
as there have been 12 conditions agreed
uh in relation to that there was one
further uh objection that was received
within time from a Mr
Patel which um made an
allegation a person connected with the
application have made un authorized
sales in the past inquiries were made
about that and there is no
subst to that alligation uh it is
therefore open
to and and but for their being delegated
powers to licensing offices it would
have been open to them to consider that
representations the
vexations under the terms of licing
act3 that would be appear to be agre
theit of action to take and if you are
satisfied that that objection is exous
uh then um the application that for be
disregarded the application should be
granted the be any live
representation thank you for that um I
too have
read representation
from wholeheartedly that it fall solidly
into the definition ofation
so
I'm
to with the adjustments ands on license
I would like
to as it
[Music]
sounds
and
so well thank you so very much I was
looking towards in presenting this but
you
speak that's that's
very
can you
these so can I just remind everybody
it's live on YouTube at the moment so
[Music]
know
theed should still be maybe
taking